[Music]
welcome anyway to this debate is
capitalism broken well it's it's only 25
years since fukuyama's claim which was
taken seriously at the time the
capitalism and liberal democracy had won
and they represented the end point of
cultural advance right but instead after
a decade of stagnation marked by
extremes of wealth and opportunity
it seems that capitalism far from being
victorious is possibly even
fundamentally broken so it's capitalism
in need of reform or is a more profound
change needed to create a fairer and an
a more equal society or perhaps despite
its flaws is capitalism still the only
game in town the only reliable driver of
improved living standards from London to
Beijing that's what we're going to talk
about tonight I need to introduce you
first so Isabella Kaminsky is editor of
FT Alphaville on the Financial Times and
before that she worked as a producer at
CNBC next we have on my right Jamie
white who is a libertarian political
philosopher he was leader of the ATT New
Zealand party guy standing who is a
world expert on universal basic income
and a professor of development at Suez
finally Stephen King who is senior
economic advisor HSBC and you were chief
economist for a long time and has he's
the author of grave new worlds the ends
of globalization and as usual I'm going
to ask each of the panel to give a very
short two or three minute pitch on the
question is capitalism broken and then
we're going to debate it so I'm gonna
start with guy what we've got today is a
system of rentier capitalism where all
the economic rules that I learnt as a
student at Cambridge have broken down it
used to be the case that the share of
national income going to capital and the
share going to labour were roughly
constant over time but it
across the world in country after
country including China in the United
States and most other countries the
share going to capital has gone up to
share going to labor has gone down but
more importantly than that the share
going to the rent ears the people who
have property and assets financial
physical or intellectual has been
shooting up let me give you one or two
key statistics which indicate a system
in crisis it used to be the case that
private wealth in this country in the
1970s was worth about 300 percent of GDP
today private wealth is 700 percent or
nearly 700 percent of GDP and the
inequality of wealth far exceeds the
inequality of earned income if you look
further at the wealth statistics you
very quickly identify the fact that over
60% of total wealth in this country is
inherited wealth in other words it's not
been earned by production or employment
or brilliance it's inherited and you can
see the same sort of phenomenon all over
the world it's not quite the pickety
story but then you see the breakdown of
simple basic economics that we were
taught at university and it used to be
the case that when productivity went up
wages went up not anymore it's called
the opening of the jaws of the snake
so when profits have gone up or
productivity have gone up average wages
have tended to fall real wages in France
in Germany and the United States have
been static and falling for the
precariat
the group that I've been writing about
for the last 30 years this is a system
in systemic crisis and this is why our
politics are also in crisis because the
basic economics that we were taught if
you work hard your income
we'll go up that's not the case anymore
millions of people work damn hard and
they're not making anything worthy of a
decent life sixty percent of the people
in poverty in this country today are in
jobs think about the implications of
that thank you very much I want to talk
quickly about what capitalism is because
if we're gonna say capitalism is broken
or capitalism is the cause of the
problems we have to know what what we
mean
now the word capitalism is a bit
unfortunate I think because it suggests
that the defining feature of capitalism
is is the use of capital capital goods
are goods you use to make goods that
you're going to consume so combine
harvesters capital good the the wheat or
the bread that so the end result is the
consumer good now capital the use of
capital and having lots of capital is
not characteristic only of capitalism as
we think of it I mean the Soviet Union
was a highly industrialized society was
lots of capital the distinguishing
feature I think of capitalism as we
usually use it and what distinguishes it
from the Soviet Union is it investment
and consumption and work are voluntary
under under capitalism or there supposed
to be and what that's a great thing
because if you're trying to get ahead in
life but you can't make people buy what
you've got to offer you have to offer
them something they want at the price
that you're charging and then somebody
also come along trying to trying to beat
you and they offer something better at
the same price or they'll find a way of
doing a cheaper and offer you that thing
and so there's a competition to get your
business and products get better and
processes get more efficient and it's
wonderfully civilizing a way of doing
things as well because it forces people
to attend to each other's wants now when
politics gets involved and politicians
start directing investment and
consumption and so on through their
decisions well now I don't have to
attend to your wants I have to attend to
the Preferences of the politicians who
are going to
Seiden and so actually I think we have
more common ground and people might
initially be expected because there's a
tendency for business people to lobby
governments to make people effectively
invest in them or buy their products
subsidies are just a form of that and
you get it you can often get a kind of
corrosion of the voluntourism but that's
the capitalism is supposed to be based
on what makes it an effective system and
I think we have seen an enormous erosion
of the voluntary we have a massive
growth in the regulation of business now
everybody thinks that that's aimed at
benefiting consumers or protecting the
public it's sold that way but as a
matter of fact is usually lobbied for by
the big businesses partly to eliminate
competition because it's very very
difficult if you're a small business to
comply with the regulatory burden in the
financial services it's just literally
impossible to be a small startup
business and the big banks and so on I
love this regulation so I think that
when you say when we say capitalism it's
broken I agree that it is I think it's
been captured that politics have been
used to benefit certain groups and we've
seen an erosion of the voluntarist
principle that is the foundation of it I
think I think we're gonna disagree about
what the remedy is I think we need to go
back to a more lays a fair approach to
economics and that the problem has been
generated precisely by political
politicians thinking they can do better
than the results you get from a
voluntary system okay
that's applause for that I think this
isn't a way match for you Jamie I'm not
an economist i watch this from a
journalistic perspective and I would
point out that there's definitely now a
market in the media arena for so-called
moral money campaigning I don't know if
you saw the FT this week but we were
free on Tuesday totally free and we we
our front page was capitalism with a
purpose so if the FT is advocating
for capitalism with the with a purpose I
think certainly there's some element of
of things having gone wrong but in terms
of how I see things as approached but as
someone who reports on this industry
what I see is not it's not necessarily
that capitalism is broken per se I think
I agree with both analyses here I do
think there's a certain element of
capitalism having been captured and and
I do think we as consumers are partly to
blame I I strongly believe that the the
monopoly situation is the problem I
think we need more competition you see
this in the sense that most of the
biggest sort of profit generators and
non probably if you look at uber uber
doesn't make any money these big
monopolies are essentially the problem
and we are partly to blame because we
facilitate them where we're going wrong
is that to continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a I dot TV
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas